que régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france qui a couvert de nombreuses
reprises
la formation au mali c'est allé
plusieurs fois faire des grands
reportages là bas régis pour paris donc
les conditions ne sont plus réunies pour
poursuivre son action militaire au mali
à quoi doit-on s'attendre demain avec
ses annonces des manuels mettront alors
c'est intéressant effectivement on sent
bien que on est à un tournant on est
plus qu à un tournant de l'opération
barkan on est à un tournant de la
pertinence de la mission française
militaire en afrique
transformer 2 2 comme en serval jusqu'à
barkan
ça fait huit ans qu'on est là
aujourd'hui il y a clairement une remise
en cause de notre présence de la part
des autorités maliennes qui lui ont
manifesté à plusieurs reprises
et il ya un problème de définition de où
va la france on sait que ce qui avait
été prévu initialement le 11 juin
dernier quand emmanuel macron annoncé
qu'en 2022 serait terminée cette
opération barkan et bien que cette
opération se transforme via la tasse
force takouba en une mission de
formation de l'armée malienne par les
forces spéciales françaises mais aussi
par les forces spéciales européennes
or on apprend la
ccc journée c'est dans les semaines qui
se sont écoulées et encore aujourd'hui
que la plupart des contingents qui ont
accepté de nous aider dans cette mission
notamment le contingent estonien moi
j'avais eu l'occasion d'aller avec eux
sur le terrain en avril dernier bien ce
contingent va se retirer le contingent
suédois ont également va se retirer le
tchèque il s'est encore en discussion et
si vous voulez la pertinence de cette
mini armées européennes de forces
spéciales qui venait au secours de
l'armée malienne parce que véritablement
il s'agit de former l'armée malienne à
tenir le terrain l'idée étant de une
fois que les forces spéciales ont
entraîné les maliens pour tenir le
terrain on ne remettent plus de forces
conventionnelles derrière et que la
france est accompli sa mission mais en
réalité cette mission elle va être
avorté et que voilà le la perte que la
france peut-elle faire aujourd'hui au
mali comment va-t-elle se redéployer
aussi dans les pays environnants
environnants est à noter par exemple
les frank france française et les forces
burkinabè ont fait énormément d'action
en commun et pas mal de succès contre
des groupes jihadistes dans les semaines
qui se sont écoulées donc est-ce que ça
va être le burkina faso c'est que
burkina faso vient de subir également un
coup d'état donc la situation est
compliquée le tchad aussi se remet
difficilement de la mort de deux pas dit
senna bré pardon de 2 comment du
président idriss voilà et il risque
qui a été remplacé par son fils mais a
néanmoins il ya quand même une
instabilité dans les pays d'afrique
aujourd'hui de notamment du g5 sahel
hormis la mauritanie qui s'en tire et le
tchad coûté à peu près arrive à garder
cette cohésion il y as péril en la
demeure donc la question de la présence
de la france est posée clairement alors
beaucoup de commentateurs se pose la
question de savoir si ici le mali on l'a
vu beaucoup dans la dans la presse
aujourd'hui sera le prochain afghanistan
a minima il s'agit d'un échec le
problème la pertinence de cette question
tient lieu à la durée de l'opération
barkan l'opération barca n'est et est
effective depuis huit ans elle a donné
des résultats il faut le prendre le le
souligner les forces françaises aux
absolument remarquablement
combattu les groupes armés terroristes
qu'on appelle les gâte salavat que ce
soit à qmi que ce soit le js éliminant
la plupart des leaders historiques de
c2c groupe men éliminant pas la menace
ce qui fait que il ya toujours
énormément d'activités
comment jihadistes dans ces zones le
problème qui se pose à barkan et aux
français en général c'est que la durée
de cette mission c'est cette mission
s'est déroulée au même moment que le
l'état malien partait en déliquescence
c'est à dire que le pays pendant ses
huit ans est véritablement disloqué il
existe aujourd'hui des pans entiers du
mali qui ne sont plus sous contrôle 2 du
gouvernement central de bamako des
services publiques ne sont plus assurées
ce sont des zones dans lesquelles des
zones de non droit dans lequel les
djihadistes sont comme des poissons dans
l'eau dans lesquelles d'autres groupes
criminels parce qu'il ya pas que les
djihadistes il ya tout un tas de trafic
est ce qu'il ya des gens les limes
avance non alors le touring fois 5000
hommes sur un pays aussi grand aussi
diverses que le méliès c'est la mission
barkan c'est la région c'est de la
mauritanie au tchad c'est plusieurs
millions de kilomètres carrés le la
question c'est que quand on met quatre
mille cinq cents hommes il faut pas
oublier cela linus pas la mission de
l'onu on est à peu près à 15000 mettons
en gros avec un millier de tchadiens qui
sont venus en renfort on est à peu près
à voilà vingt mille 20 mille soldats
pour un p pour une zone en effet vous
l'avez remarqué qui est extrêmement
difficile à pacifier le sahel recouvre
des réalités ethniques des réalités
religieuses des réalités
comment culturel très différentes la
question aussi de la chasse aux
terroristes et les ailettes elle est
posée est ce que l'armée française a
suffisamment fait de contre insurrection
par exemple on sait que les américains
ont pratiqué c'est tactique de guerre
pour essayer justement de ramener la
communauté sunnite arabes sunnites dans
la nation irakienne pour justement
lutter contre al qaïda ça a été
relativement efficace là est ce qu on
est allé suffisamment vers les peuls
vers les touareg est ce qu'il ya eu des
programmes finalement qui ont permis
justement à destination de ces
populations nomades qui sont les plus
problématiques aujourd'hui et résista
envoie en direct évidemment cette heure
réunion a consacré à ce désengagement en
tout cas aux contours d'un futur
dispositif militaire
régionale avec les chefs d'état du sahel
ce divorce entre guillemets entre les
autorités maliennes et la france il est
aussi le divorce avec d'autres pays
évidemment la du sahel et au mali
aujourd'hui vous avez au moins quatre
pays dans cette zone qui qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des gouvernements de
transition c'est un sa tendance à se
répéter c'est à dire il ya un coup
d'état il ya une junte militaire qui
prend le pouvoir et un gouvernement de
transition ça veut dire les militaires
s'occupe du pouvoir en attendant qui est
des élections et on se rend compte que
ni au tchad neoma dit jusqu'à présent le
calendrier électoral n'a été établi ce
qui fait que les militaires en attendant
reste au pouvoir donc le presque on va
voir se multiplier on a vu la
guinée-bissau l'autre jour qui a eu une
tentative de coup d'état vous avez la
guinée où il ya eu un coup d'état avec
pareil un gouvernement de transition le
burkina récemment donc voilà il ya une
instabilité qui se fait une
insatisfaction aussi face à la question
sécuritaire que les maliens sont
président ivoirien dit ce soir le départ
de la france va laisser un grand vide 1
c'est ce qu'ils disent ce soir comment
on peut imaginer le mali se préparer
justement ce départ alors moi je pense
que ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'il ya à la fois au
mali j'étais moins vendent avant noël
pardon à la fois un sentiment 2 comment
dire d'insécurité de peur justement de
la suite et en même temps une
exacerbation du sentiment anti français
c'est assez paradoxal mais il n'y a pas
si vous voulez de haine anti-française
faut pas non plus dire que par exemple
les français sont pas menacées à monaco
n'y a pas des gens dans la rue qui
brûlent des drapeaux français mais il y
a des mots il ya parfois des
manifestations violentes à notre endroit
des commandes et pancartes très hostiles
à la france mais il n'y a pas je dirais
cette haine parce que les maliens ne
déteste pas les français
c'est maintenant je pense que le
gouvernement français peut-être n'a pas
assez anticipé le coup d'état en fait ne
l'a pas vu venir d'abord et ce coup
d'état en fait il est venue en réponse
aux carences du gouvernement précédent
qui était précisément l'alliée de la
france c'était donc le président ibrahim
keita
comment surnommé ib cas qui pendant
plusieurs années a finalement incarner
cette corruption incarner se manie qui
partait à vau de l'eau les français se
sont appuyés sur lui et puis un jour il
ya eu coup d'état est ce qu'on a vu on a
vu ces militaires au pouvoir se faire
applaudir par le peuple c'est assez
étonnant mais ces militaires sont
populaires et je pense qu'on a mal
négocié ça on a mal négocié l'arrivée
justement ce changement on l'a pas vu
venir il ya également la façon dont
emmanuel macron a annoncé la fin de
l'opération barkan sans prévenir les
maliens d'où peut tous là là comment le
pool à la phrase prononcée par un show
girl maïga à la tribune de l'onu disant
que les maliens avaient l'impression que
la france les abandonner en plein vol
donc il ya ce sentiment effectivement
d'un vide qui va qui va il est évident
que toutes les discussions autour de la
présence ou non de la cmp wagner dans la
région des discussions qui pourraient
avoir la smp wagner n'a pas vocation à
remplacer barkan ce que je recherche le
mali aujourd'hui c'est que comme la
partenariat avec la france est en passe
d'être achevés ou d'être de se finir et
bien le mali cherche d'autres
partenaires y a pas que la russie et la
chine y ré turquie laquelle directement
le le premier ministre malien fait des
appels du pied l'autre l'autre jour la
turquie on sait est extrêmement présente
dans la région elle a investi
massivement c'est elle qui a refait
l'aéroport de niamey par exemple au
niger voisin elle a aussi investi au
sénégal donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup
voilà 2 2 deux possibilités
et le fait est qu'aujourd'hui la
présence française
defacto recul voilà merci régis le
sommier alors que cette réunion les
protagonistes en tout cas qui vont
assister à cette réunion sont en train
d'arriver en des accolades chaleureuses
heureusement qu'elle est mal ce camp
parce qu on se dirait tiens on se refait
la bise à l'elysée voilà en tout cas
c'est très chaleureux manifestement
entre l'accueil entre le président macro
et ses invités merci ray c'était pour la
petite aparté verser on n'est pas chez
boris johnson n'ont effectivement rien
les masses à l'hommage c'est peut-être
moins festif effectivement merci
beaucoup en tout cas régis le sommier
pour ce décryptage